When you name names, when you snitch, when you drop a dime, when you shop somebody, when you're a canary or a rat or a stool pigeon, when you squeal, or when you tattle, often you prefer to remain anonymous. And so the next voice that you're going to hear is somebody whose name you will never know. And when her story begins, she is just another hapless, nearsighted citizen like you and me.
当你指名道姓、告密、通风报信、出卖他人，或者当你是走狗、叛徒、线人，当你告发或嚼舌根时，你通常希望保持匿名。所以你接下来听到的这个声音，是这样一个人的，你永远不会知道她的名字。当她的故事开始时，她和你我一样，只是一个倒霉、近视的普通市民。
I went to get laser vision correction. And following the surgery, one of my eyes turned out totally fine, but the other one had a problem, double vision. So that was just kind of strange. And under the contract, they tell you in the agreement that it may not turn out perfectly. But within the first year, if there are any problems, you are offered free touch ups for the procedure.
我去做了激光视力矫正手术。手术后，我的一只眼睛完全没问题，但另一只眼出了问题，出现重影。所以这真的很奇怪。根据合同，他们在协议里告诉过你，手术结果可能不够完美。但在第一年内，如果出现任何问题，他们会为你提供免费的矫正手术。
So she waited several months after the first surgery for her eyes to heal, did everything her doctor said she should. She even went to a second eye doctor who checked her out, told her, "No big deal." She was an easy case. "Tell your regular doctor to sit you in the chair, set the laser to these coordinates." The second doctor actually gave her the right settings. "And you will be all patched up." So she makes an appointment for surgery with her original doctor.
于是她在第一次手术后等待了几个月让眼睛恢复，做了一切医生叮嘱她该做的事。她甚至去找了第二位眼科医生检查，医生告诉她：“没大碍。”她的情况很简单。“告诉你的主治医生让你坐到椅子上，把激光调到这些坐标。”第二位医生实际上给出了正确的设置。“这样你就会完全恢复了。”于是她预约了原先医生的手术。
And on the day of, I was very shocked. I was told by the doctor that I could not get the surgery after all and that he was recommending a totally different course of treatment. He wanted me to close my eyes and then press my thumb on my eyelid a couple of times a day, which just seemed a little odd to me.
在手术当天，我非常震惊。医生告诉我，我最终还是做不了手术，并且他建议采取完全不同的治疗方案。他让我闭上眼睛，然后每天在眼皮上按压拇指几次，这对我来说显得有点奇怪。
You'd think that science had gotten further than that.
你以为科学应该比这更进步才对。
Exactly. That just seemed bizarre. So I questioned him about it. And he started to get very agitated. And he was talking about how he was an expert in this field, and he knew what he was doing. And if I went to any other eye doctor anywhere else who was an expert in the field, they would tell me the exact same thing.
确实。那看起来简直荒唐。所以我质疑了他。他开始变得非常激动。他大谈特谈他是这个领域的专家，他知道自己在做什么。而且如果我去找这个领域的任何其他眼科专家，他们也会告诉我完全一样的话。
And so I brought up the fact that I had the second opinion. And he got more upset. His voice just got really loud-- and just saying really weird things. He started bringing up the fact that he had a lawsuit. He started bringing up how everyone wants to be like Michael Jordan, but not everyone can. It was bizarre. He was just throwing out all these weird statements at me.
所以我提到了我有第二诊疗意见的事。他变得更生气了。他的嗓门变得很大——还说了一些真的很奇怪的话。他开始提起他正面临一场诉讼。他开始谈论每个人都想成为迈克尔·乔丹，但不是每个人都能做到。这太荒唐了。他只是向我抛出所有这些奇怪的言论。
Wait, wait, wait. He was bringing up the fact that he had a lawsuit?
等等，等等。他提到了他正面临一场诉讼？
Yes, he did. He was saying that he tries to help people. But he tried to help this person, and now he's getting sued for it because it didn't turn out well.
是的，他提到了。他说他努力去帮助别人。但他试图帮助这个人，现在却因为结果不理想而被起诉。
You get the picture. He yells, she cries. She quietly notices that all of his other patients, like her, are immigrants. And she wonders if he's just in business to take advantage of people, that he's just going to stall her until the year has run out for her free touch up, so she'll have to pay. They call the AMA, they lodge a complaint with the Better Business Bureau, they call the Department of Professional Practices. Nothing gets results. It's frustrating. Months go by, and remember, she is still seeing double every minute she's awake.
你明白是怎么回事了。他大吼，她大哭。她默默注意到他的其他病人像她一样都是移民。她怀疑他做生意只是为了利用别人，他只是想拖延时间直到她免费矫正的期限过期，这样她就得付费。他们给美国医学会（AMA）打电话，向商业改善局（BBB）投诉，还致电职业实践部门。什么都没有结果。这让人感到沮丧。几个月过去了，请记住，她醒着的每一分钟仍然看着重影。
So I was very upset. And weirdly enough, I was talking about this with my therapist. And she was the one who suggested getting revenge. She said that a great way to mess with someone's head, even though you don't necessarily see the results, was to call the IRS on them. And so--
所以我非常难过。奇怪的是，我正在和我的心理治疗师谈论这件事。是她建议我报复。她说，即便你不一定能看到结果，干扰某人的心智也是一个很好的报复方式，就是给国税局（IRS）打电话举报他们。所以——
You called the IRS on the guy?
你给国税局举报了那个人？
I did write a letter. I did write three letters in fact.
我确实写了一封信。事实上，我写了三封。
OK, let us just say here, straight up, that this is very, very wrong. There is no two ways about it. Starting with the fact that for a therapist to instruct a patient on how to mess with someone's head is pretty much a prima facie violation of the Hippocratic oath, if therapists even take the Hippocratic oath. But she did not stop there.
好吧，让我们直接在这里说，这非常、非常错误。这是毋庸置疑的。首先，治疗师教导病人如何干扰他人的心智，这几乎是公然违背希波克拉底誓言，如果治疗师真的有发过希波克拉底誓言的话。但她并没有就此罢休。
And then the other thing that she suggested was--
然后她建议的另一件事是——
Your therapist, right?
你的治疗师，对吧？
Yes. --was to call building violations on him.
是的。——是去举报他违反建筑规范。
Basically, to call in the city.
基本上就是去向市政府举报。
Yeah, which she said was another great way to mess with someone's head, because she was saying that no matter how stupid the offense is or how minor it is, you just have to fix it.
对，她说这是干扰某人心理的另一种好方法，因为她说无论违规行为多么愚蠢或微小，你都必须去修复它。
He had messed with her. He had been imperious. He had been immovable and irrational. And now he would face the most imperious, immovable, irrational foe imaginable, the government of the United States of America in its federal and local manifestations.
他曾干扰了她的生活。他曾高高在上、顽固不化且不可理喻。现在，他将面对想象中最傲慢、最顽固、最不可理喻的对手——美利坚合众国政府，无论是在联邦还是地方层面。
There would be auditors. He would have to locate old financial papers. Meanwhile, the building inspectors would have him spending hours on hold waiting for this office or that office to tell him what forms and permits. You know what I'm talking about here.
会有审计人员。他必须找出陈旧的财务文件。与此同时，建筑检查员会让他花几个小时在线等待，询问这个办公室或那个办公室，告诉他需要什么表格和许可证。你知道我在说什么吧。
And yes, this is wrong, very, very tragically wrong. But who among us has not been in some situation, where the phone company, or some contractor, or the doctor, whoever, has messed with us enough that we want revenge? I think there are lots of us who would feel like this woman in that situation. We would call in the feds, and we would not feel bad about it.
是的，这是错的，非常、非常悲剧性地错了。但我们之中谁没遇过那种情况，电话公司、承包商、医生，不管是谁，把我们折腾得够呛，让我们想报复？我想在那种情况下，我们当中有很多人会像这位女士一样。我们会叫联邦政府来管，而且不会感到内疚。
Either I don't have a conscience or I just am so firm in my belief that he deserves it.
要么我没有良心，要么我就是非常坚定地认为他罪有应得。
That, in fact, he deserves it.
事实上，他罪有应得。
Yeah.
是的。
And you had no other recourse?
而且你别无他法了？
Right.
对。
Now I have to say, I think this kind of case is very rare. I think usually, usually, when people turn in other people to the government, there is a twinge of guilt or often more than a twinge. Today on our radio program, we bring you several stories of people who named names. And in all those stories, the accuser is just as torn up about it as the accused.
现在我不得不说，我认为这种案例非常罕见。我认为通常情况下，当人们向政府举报他人时，会有一种负罪感，或者往往不止是一点点。今天在我们的电台节目中，我们为您带来了几个“指名道姓”的人的故事。在所有这些故事中，告发者和被告者一样备受煎熬。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in three revelatory acts. Act One, How Britain Nearly Saved America. In that act, Jon Ronson tells the true story of his personal role in a post-September 11 news crisis that you are very familiar with and his misgivings about his role.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是由公共广播国际（PRI）发行的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们今天的节目分为三个发人深省的章节。第一章，《英国差一点拯救了美国》。在这一章中，乔恩·罗森（Jon Ronson）讲述了他在9月11日之后的一场新闻危机中，自己扮演的真实角色，以及他对自己所作所为的疑虑。
Act Two, One Crucible Leads to Another. In that act, a conversation from 1952 as the House Un-American Activities Committee was asking people to squeal on Communist friends and colleagues. And how, even today, it is hard to agree on what was said in private.
第二章，《一个磨难引向另一个》。在这一章中，一段1952年的对话，当时众议院非美活动调查委员会（HUAC）正在要求人们告发共产主义朋友和同事。即使在今天，对于私下里说了什么，也很难达成共识。
Act Three, Beating the Erasers. How a small town in Tennessee rose up against a few middle-aged grade school teachers very recently. Stay with us.
第三章，《击败橡皮擦的人》。最近田纳西州一个小镇是如何反抗几名中年小学教师的。请继续收听。
Act One, How Britain Nearly Saved America. Well, Jon Ronson has appeared on our program before. Over the last few years, he has done a series of documentaries for British television about political and religious extremists, stories that are remarkable because they are often surprisingly funny, given the subject matter. And he tells this story which occurred in the immediate wake of September 11. It was October, and anthrax scares and terrible anthrax news were everyday occurrences. Jon was in London at the time, where he lives.
第一章，《英国差一点拯救了美国》。乔恩·罗森以前曾在我们的节目中出现过。过去几年里，他为英国电视台拍摄了一系列关于政治和宗教极端分子的纪录片。这些故事很引人注目，因为考虑到主题，它们往往出奇地有趣。他讲述了这个发生在9月11日事件后不久的故事。那是十月，炭疽热恐慌和关于炭疽的可怕新闻是每天都在发生的事情。乔恩当时住在伦敦。
On a Saturday night last October, my friend and producer John Sergeant called me. "Hi, Jon," he said. I recognized a delicate blend of urgency, paranoia, and panic in his voice. You'd have to be a connoisseur of his neurotic vocal patterns to spot it. I wondered what it was this time.
去年十月的一个星期六晚上，我的朋友兼制片人约翰·萨金特给我打了电话。“嗨，乔恩，”他说。我从他的声音中识别出了一种急迫、偏执和恐慌的微妙混合。你得是那种神经质声调的鉴赏家才能察觉出来。我纳闷这次又是什么事。
During our years together documenting extremist groups, we've become variously convinced we're being followed by the Mafia, Aryan Nations, the BATF, and the CIA. It wouldn't be fair to blame the extremists and say that all their paranoia has rubbed off on me and John. The fact is we've always been neurotic. If anything, we tend to connect with our interviewees over a shared sense of paranoia.
在我们记录极端组织的那些年里，我们曾先后确信自己被黑手党、雅利安国、烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局（BATF）以及中央情报局（CIA）跟踪。把一切归咎于极端分子，说他们的偏执传染给了我和约翰，这不公平。事实是，我们一直都很神经质。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是我们往往会因为一种共有的偏执感而与采访对象产生共鸣。
The irony is that my neurosis comes, I guess, from being Jewish, whereas theirs usually manifests itself in a hatred of the Jews. John's got no excuse. He's Church of England. He's just a neurotic. But for all our regular descents into paranoia, nothing bad has ever actually happened to us. And I was getting tired of all the panicky phone calls.
讽刺的是，我想我的神经质是因为身为犹太人，而他们的神经质通常表现为对犹太人的仇恨。约翰可没什么借口。他是英国国教徒。他纯粹就是个神经质。但在我们历次的偏执发作中，从没真正发生过什么坏事。我厌倦了那些恐慌的电话。
"I think," said John, "that we may know who's been sending all the anthrax." "Who?" I asked. "Tim," he said. I sighed, trying not to sound patronizing. "Who's Tim?" I said. John sighed, trying not to sound patronizing. "Tim who told us a year ago that the way to fight the government was to send anthrax through the mail," he said. "Oh, that Tim," I said.
“我想，”约翰说，“我们可能知道是谁在寄那些炭疽包裹了。”“谁？”我问。“蒂姆，”他说。我叹了口气，尽量不表现出傲慢。“蒂姆是谁？”我说。约翰叹了口气，尽量不表现出傲慢。“蒂姆，就是一年前告诉我们对抗政府的方法是邮寄炭疽邮件的那个人，”他说。“哦，是那个蒂姆，”我说。
John and I had met Tim a year earlier at a gun show in Rochester, Minnesota. We were there with Randy Weaver. The crowds flocked to get the autograph of this icon of the anti-government right, this Ruby Ridge survivor, whose wife and son were killed by federal snipers. But Tim didn't.
约翰和我在一年前明尼苏达州罗切斯特的一个枪展上遇到了蒂姆。我们当时和兰迪·韦弗（Randy Weaver）在一起。人群蜂拥而至，想要这位反政府右翼偶像、那位妻子和儿子被联邦狙击手杀害的红宝石岭（Ruby Ridge）幸存者的签名。但蒂姆没有。
He stood apart, a lone wolf amongst lone wolves, a pasty-looking man wearing a lumberjack shirt and glasses. He had a deep grudge against the federal government and, it turned out, the rudimentary scientific knowledge of a lab technician. He told us that anthrax was the only way forward for the movement.
他站在一边，是一个独行狼中的独行狼，一个脸色苍白、穿着伐木工衬衫、戴着眼镜的男人。他对联邦政府怀有深仇大恨，而且事实证明，他还具备实验室技术员的基本科学知识。他告诉我们，炭疽是该运动向前的唯一途径。
In our experience, anthrax wasn't a big militia topic of conversation. In fact, we had never heard anyone mention it before. I had figured Tim was just another gun show kook. But John recognized his uniqueness and wanted him on tape. So he went off to interview him on video.
根据我们的经验，炭疽并不是民兵圈子里的热门谈话话题。事实上，我们之前从未听人提起过。我以为蒂姆只是另一个枪展上的怪人。但约翰意识到他的独特性，想要把他拍下来。于是他去录下对他的采访。
We never did anything with the tape. It was B-roll to me, just a vox pop, a 20-minute chat. It had sat in my cupboard for a year. Now I dug it out, I put it into the VCR, and I pressed play.
我们当时没处理这段录像。对我来说，那是花絮（B-roll），只是街头采访，一段20分钟的聊天。它在我的柜子里放了一年。现在我把它翻出来，放进录像机，按下了播放键。
Can you just tell us where we are, and what you're doing here?
你能告诉我们我们在哪里，在这里做什么吗？
We're at a gun show here in Rochester, Minnesota. I sell books that teach you how to make explosives, incendiaries, booby traps. And I also get into the more dangerous biological and chemical weapons area, the bioweapons area being that you can mail the weapons in microscopic form under a postage stamp or taped to a letter with color pictures and instructions on how to do it. And that way, you can rearm the entire nation if the government ever tries to take the guns away. One person, by themselves, anybody with this knowledge can rearm everybody in a day.
我们是在明尼苏达州罗切斯特的枪展上。我卖教你如何制造爆炸物、燃烧弹、诱杀装置的书。我也深入研究了更危险的生物和化学武器领域，生物武器领域就是你可以以微观形式通过邮票邮寄这些武器，或者贴在带彩色图片和操作说明的信件上。这样，如果政府试图收缴枪支，你可以武装整个国家。一个人，独自一人，任何掌握这知识的人一天内就能武装所有人。
The people we met at the gun shows all had their own special ways of theoretically battling the government. One guy had advocated the use of piano wire to me. Another favored firebombs. Tim's big thing was anthrax. At the time, I thought it was just blather.
我们在枪展上遇到的人都有自己理论上对抗政府的特殊方法。有人向我提倡使用钢琴弦。另一个人偏爱燃烧弹。蒂姆的“大招”是炭疽。当时，我以为这只是空谈。
Tim didn't look frightening. He looked friendly, like someone's dad. Picture all that talk about chemical weaponry coming out of the mouth of Roger Ebert, and you get the idea. But now the words were chilling and so was the matter-of-fact delivery.
蒂姆看起来并不吓人。他看起来很友好，就像某人的父亲。想象一下罗杰·伊伯特（Roger Ebert）口中吐出那些关于化学武器的言论，你就有概念了。但现在这些话让人不寒而栗，他那种就事论事的陈述方式也是。
"I should call the FBI," I said to John quickly. "Hang on," he said, "I'm the one who thought of Tim. I should call the FBI." "I want to call the FBI," I said. I was the senior partner in this relationship. I was the reporter. If anyone was going to call the feds, it was going to be me.
“我应该给FBI打电话，”我快速对约翰说。“等等，”他说，“是我先想到蒂姆的。我应该给FBI打电话。”“我想打给FBI，”我说。我是这段关系中的资深合伙人。我是记者。如果有人要叫联邦政府，那也应该是我。
"Well, I don't want you bloody going to the FBI without me," said John. There was a hurt silence. I heard him breathing heavily on the other end of the phone, gearing up for a fight. "OK," I said, "I promise to bring you with me to the FBI."
“好吧，我不希望你该死地一个人跑去找FBI而不带我，”约翰说。一阵受伤的沉默。我听到他在电话那头粗重地呼吸，准备要吵架了。“好吧，”我说，“我答应带你一起去FBI。”
I'd never ratted out an interviewee to the feds before. I had never given up a source. This would normally be a very bad thing for a journalist to do. But you have to remember the panic and fear everyone was feeling that October. Every day that month over 100 anthrax letters were reported. One morning, anthrax was proven at ABC News. The next day, Senate offices were closed. The next, the House of Representatives shut down. Postal workers were dying.
在此之前，我从未向联邦调查局告发过任何受访者。我从未出卖过消息来源。这通常是记者大忌。但你必须记住每个人在那个十月感到的恐慌和恐惧。那个月每天都有超过100封炭疽邮件的报告。一天早上，美国广播公司新闻部（ABC News）证实了炭疽包裹。第二天，参议院办公室关闭。再下一天，众议院关闭。邮政工人正在死去。
Plus, there was nothing Deep Throat about our relationship with Tim. He didn't speak with us in confidence or ask that we withhold his name. He wanted people to know his ideas about anthrax. He started gabbing loudly to John about anthrax the minute they started chatting.
况且，我们与蒂姆的关系根本没有所谓的“深喉”性质。他没有私下和我们交谈，也没有要求我们要保密。他希望人们知道他关于炭疽的想法。他们开始聊天的那一刻，他就开始对约翰大声谈论炭疽。
It wasn't easy to find the FBI in London. Directory assistance had no record of them. "Are you sure F stands for Federal?" they said. I finally tracked them to the US Embassy, and an agent called Michael came onto the phone.
在伦敦找到FBI并不容易。查号台没有他们的记录。“你确定F代表联邦（Federal）吗？”他们问。我终于在驻英大使馆追踪到了他们，一位名叫迈克尔（Michael）的特工接了电话。
When I told him what I had, he said casually, "Yes, that would be something we'd be interested in. Could you bring it in?" "Tomorrow?" I asked. And Michael agreed. I realized that things were less casual when, the next morning, at 8:30 AM, Michael telephoned to ask if I was coming in today. Things aren't casual at 8:30 AM. People call at 8:30 AM if they've been up worrying about things.
当我告诉他我有什么东西时，他随意地说：“是的，这确实是我们感兴趣的事。你能带过来吗？”“明天？”我问。迈克尔同意了。我意识到情况并不像我想的那么随意，因为第二天早上8:30，迈克尔打电话来询问我今天是否会过去。在早上8:30，事情可不随意。人们在早上8:30打电话，如果他们整晚都在为此担忧的话。
Two hours later, in Grosvenor Square, West London, John and I were past the exterior security guards, quadrupled in the wake of September 11, past the ocean of fencing, the acres of dead sidewalk space between the fencing and the concrete posts designed to stop suicide bombers, through the x-rays, the bag search, up the elevator, through a series of specially enforced steel doors-- the kind of doors you find on safes-- through more corridors, through the body search, and into London's FBI headquarters. It was incredibly exciting to be there and to be part of it all at this extraordinary moment in history. And let there be no mistake about this, we walked in thinking we were heroes.
两小时后，在西伦敦的格罗夫纳广场，我和约翰穿过了9月11日之后加强了四倍防守的外部保安哨卡，穿过了一片篱笆的海洋，穿过了设计用来阻挡自杀式炸弹袭击者的围栏和混凝土柱之间的广阔空地，经过了X光检查、包包检查，乘电梯上去，穿过一系列专门加固的钢门——那种你在保险库里才能看到的门——穿过更多的走廊，经过身体检查，进入了伦敦的FBI总部。能来到这里并在这个非凡的历史时刻成为其中的一部分，真是令人兴奋不已。别搞错了，我们走进那里时以为自己是英雄。
We were led into an office decorated with novelty tourist trinkets, Big Ben snowstorms, and a collection of funny police helmets. These chachkas struck me as a heartbreaking stab at normal office life amid the craziness deep behind the barricades.
我们被带进一间装饰着旅游纪念品、大本钟雪花球和各种搞笑警察头盔的办公室。这些小玩意儿在我看来是身处路障深处疯狂环境中，对正常办公生活的一种心碎的尝试。
Michael was sitting behind his desk. He was bookish, and young, and soberly dressed. He stood up, and shook our hands, and led us through to his boss's office, and sat us on the sofa. He got out his notepad and said, "So how did you come to meet this Tim?"
迈克尔坐在他的办公桌后面。他文质彬彬，年轻，穿着严谨。他站起来，与我们握手，把我们带到他老板的办公室，让我们坐在沙发上。他拿出笔记本说：“那么，你们是怎么遇到这位蒂姆的？”
"Well," said John, "we're journalists, and we were following Randy Weaver around the gun show circuit. Actually, no, no, Jon had hooked up with Randy Weaver a few days earlier, but I'd been researching another project-- would you believe it-- surveillance cameras in shopping malls." John laughed nervously. Michael's eyes began to glaze. I think that John, like many people who meet law enforcement officers, was feeling the desperate urge to confess. Luckily, John didn't have anything to confess to. So this compulsion was finding a different outlet, mad small talk.
“好吧，”约翰说，“我们是记者，当时正跟着兰迪·韦弗走访枪展。其实，不，不，乔恩早几天就联系上了兰迪·韦弗，但我当时正在研究另一个项目——你敢相信吗——购物中心里的监控摄像头。”约翰紧张地笑了。迈克尔的眼睛开始失焦。我认为约翰像许多见到执法人员的人一样，感到了强烈的坦白冲动。幸运的是，约翰没什么好坦白的。所以这种强迫感找到了另一个宣泄口：疯狂闲聊。
I glanced down at Michael's notepad. So far, he'd only written two words, Randy Weaver. "Shall we watch the tape?" Said Michael. He hit play.
我扫了一眼迈克尔的笔记本。到目前为止，他只写了两个词：兰迪·韦弗。“我们要看录像吗？”迈克尔说。他按下了播放键。
The only way American people can defend themselves from criminals has been with firearms or-- in the case of the government and the Army, firearms are going to be relatively worthless. So I had to look at some practical methods of which American people could arm themselves and fight back if they ever had to. And that's where the biological story came from.
美国人民捍卫自己免受罪犯伤害的唯一方法是使用枪支或者——在政府和军队的情况下，枪支将相对无用。所以我必须研究一些实际的方法，让美国人民能够武装自己，如果他们必须反击的话。这就是生物武器故事的由来。
John and I sat there, beaming with pride. We were so sure we had the guy. Michael's facial expression was pointedly unreadable.
约翰和我坐在那里，洋溢着自豪。我们如此确定我们抓到了那个人。迈克尔的面部表情故意让人无法解读。
One person could, for example, mass propagate it and deliver it. And you could render most of the major cities uninhabitable in about a week, which would wreck the economy and pretty much put an end to the government.
一个人可以，例如，大规模传播并投放它。你可以在大约一周内让大多数主要城市变得无法居住，这将摧毁经济，并彻底终结政府。
Tim, can I just ask you, what you're actually advocating here is the spread of really dangerous information. On what grounds? Why do you feel that it's a good idea for everyone to know this terrible stuff?
蒂姆，我能问一下吗，你在这里实际倡导的是散布非常危险的信息。基于什么理由？你为什么觉得让每个人都知道这些可怕的事情是个好主意？
I was relieved that John had adopted a combative style of questioning with Tim. All too often, John and I ask extremists overly soft questions that might lead FBI agents to erroneously believe that we have gone native and are, in some way, sympathetic to extremist causes or unsympathetic to officers of the law. And sure enough, a moment later in the interview, I was mortified to hear the following exchange. Tim had just told John that the majority of gun show attendees are actually undercover federal agents.
看到约翰对蒂姆采取了对抗性的质问风格，我感到如释重负。我和约翰太经常问那些极端分子过于温和的问题了，以至于FBI特工可能会错误地认为我们已经“入乡随俗”，并在某种程度上同情极端事业或不同情执法人员。果不其然，片刻后，我因为听到随后的对话而感到羞愧。蒂姆刚刚告诉约翰，大多数枪展参与者其实都是卧底联邦特工。
What proportion do you think might be, then, today government agencies here in this event today?
那你认为今天在这里，政府机构的人员比例可能有多大？
In the summertime, the law enforcement presence runs anywhere from 50% to 90% during summer. And during the winter, reliably, in the range of 30% to 60%.
在夏天，执法部门的出现率在50%到90%之间。而到了冬天，稳定在30%到60%之间。
Michael laughed, and said he wished they had that kind of budget. John and I laughed too.
迈克尔笑了，说他希望他们有那么多的预算。约翰和我也笑了。
So you're saying as many as 90% of the people here could be actually federal agents of one form or another?
所以你是说这里多达90%的人实际上是某种形式的联邦特工？
Yes, that's correct.
是的，没错。
Don't you think that's a pretty outrageous and rude statement to make to all these nice people here?
你不觉得对所有这些可爱的人说这种话是非常离谱和粗鲁的吗？
"Oh dear," I thought. "Should I have edited that bit out before calling the FBI? Or would that have been tampering with evidence?" I shifted awkwardly on the sofa, and I glanced up at Michael. He was sitting behind his desk. He'd put John and me on the low sofa, so we had to look up at him. I watched his face flash with disappointment when Tim started telling this cautionary tale from his own life on the video.
“哦天哪，”我心想。“我在给FBI打电话之前应该把那一段剪掉吗？还是说那会算作篡改证据？”我在沙发上尴尬地挪动了一下，抬头看了看迈克尔。他坐在办公桌后面。他让约翰和我坐在低矮的沙发上，所以我们不得不仰视他。当蒂姆在视频中开始讲述他自己生活中这个告诫故事时，我看着他的脸闪过一丝失望。
When you're sitting in the house with a shotgun, and they send the Army out to your house over a book you wrote, and they're sitting outside, that was ridiculous. I have been targeted. And that's no secret. It has already been in the papers, in The Washington Post and in some of the other papers.
当你坐在家里拿着霰弹枪，而他们因为你写的一本书派军队去你家，他们坐在外面，那太荒谬了。我被针对了。这不是什么秘密。它已经上过报纸了，在《华盛顿邮报》和其他报纸上。
At this point, I started to worry that maybe I'd oversold the videotape when I was on the phone with Michael. If the government and media already knew about Tim, maybe this wasn't such a hot tip. Michael said, "Well, it's interesting to hear these guys talk," which I took to mean, this is wasting my time. I suddenly felt silly and abashed. It was like taking someone to your favorite movie and seeing it for the first time through their eyes. And they're bored, and restless, and disappointed. And you start to think, it maybe wasn't such a great movie anyway.
此时，我开始担心，也许我在给迈克尔打电话时夸大了这段录像的价值。如果政府和媒体已经知道蒂姆了，也许这不是什么重磅线索。迈克尔说：“嗯，听听这些家伙谈论很有意思，”我理解为：这在浪费我的时间。我突然感到愚蠢和羞愧。这就像带某人去看你最喜欢的电影，然后通过他们的眼睛第一次看它。他们感到无聊、焦躁和失望。你开始觉得，这电影也许本来就没那么好。
When the tape ended, Michael thanked us, and he escorted us back to the lobby. We had to hand in our security passes, and John couldn't find his. He fumbled around in his pockets. "You put it in your bag," said Michael softly, "while you were watching the video." It must have taken John a split second to put the pass in his bag, just an absentminded move made while we were all watching the video. I was impressed. What else had Michael noticed about us that we didn't even know about ourselves?
录像结束时，迈克尔感谢了我们，并护送我们回到大厅。我们必须上交安全通行证，而约翰找不到他的了。他在口袋里乱翻。“你把它放在包里了，”迈克尔轻声说，“就在你看视频的时候。”约翰把通行证放进包里一定只花了一秒钟，那是在我们都看视频时做出的一个心不在焉的动作。我被震撼了。迈克尔还注意到了我们什么，而我们自己甚至不知道？
That night, as I lay in bed, I thought of Tim. And I wondered who he really was. A week later, the Wall Street Journal provided the answers to these questions. The Journal reported that the FBI were looking for a homegrown anthrax terrorist. And they were making inquiries about a Nebraska man called Tim Tobiason who was known on the gun show circuit for advocating the use of anthrax. There was a photograph. This was my Tim.
那天晚上，当我躺在床上时，我想到了蒂姆。我纳闷他到底是谁。一周后，《华尔街日报》给出了问题的答案。《华尔街日报》报道称，FBI正在寻找一名本土炭疽恐怖分子。他们正在调查一名叫蒂姆·托比亚森（Tim Tobiason）的内布拉斯加州男子，此人在枪展圈子里以倡导使用炭疽而闻名。有一张照片。这就是我的蒂姆。
The FBI had apparently been alerted by a member of the public. "Wow," I thought, "they must have gone after him anyway." A Google search filled in the gaps. Tim Tobiason came from Silver Creek, Nebraska. He was once a pillar of the community, the owner of an animal feed mill and an old Dairy Queen, with 24 employees and $3 million a year cash flow, married, two daughters, and a chemical wizard too, mixing up witches' brews at night in his garage. "Funny smelling stuff," said his neighbors.
FBI显然是接到了公众成员的举报。“哇，”我想，“他们肯定无论如何都会去追捕他的。”谷歌搜索填补了空白。蒂姆·托比亚森来自内布拉斯加州的银溪（Silver Creek）。他曾是社区的支柱，一家动物饲料厂和一家老式冰雪皇后（Dairy Queen）的老板，拥有24名员工和每年300万美元的现金流，已婚，有两个女儿，还是个化学奇才，晚上在车库里调制着“女巫汤”。“闻起来怪怪的东西，”邻居们说。
He made some anthrax and a whole new kind of phosphate-based feed additive, which he calculated would net him millions. He set about patenting it, but the government said it would be dangerous to cattle. So they rejected it. He began bitching to his friends about a conspiracy, how the government had stolen his patent and given it to some agricultural corporation. "This is what they do," he said, "rob the small guy, the garage chemist, to line the pockets of the giants."
他制造了一些炭疽和一种全新的磷基饲料添加剂，他计算过这将为他带来数百万美元的收入。他着手申请专利，但政府说这对牛来说太危险了。所以他们拒绝了。他开始向朋友抱怨阴谋，说政府如何窃取了他的专利并给了某家农业公司。“这就是他们干的事，”他说，“抢走小人物、车库化学家的成果，去填满巨头的腰包。”
He moved into a Dodge Caravan and plotted his revenge. He wrote Scientific Principles of Improvised Warfare: Advanced Biological Weapons Design and Manufacture. The cover promised, "If you can make Jell-O, you can wipe out cities. Enjoy!" His marriage collapsed. And he took to selling his book on the gun show circuit.
他搬进了一辆道奇Caravan货车，策划复仇。他写了《简易战争的科学原理：高级生物武器的设计与制造》。封面上承诺：“如果你能做果冻，你就能毁灭城市。享受吧！”他的婚姻破裂了。他开始在枪展上兜售他的书。
In the wake of the Journal article, TV crews stormed Silver Creek. But Tim had vanished. The FBI analyzed his handwriting. They followed the instructions in his anthrax cookbook and found them to be shoddy and incomplete. They concluded Tim Tobiason was innocent. As a result of the publicity, Tim was banned from gun shows across the United States. His Silver Creek neighbors said they didn't expect him back, which was all for the best because he was no longer welcome in town.
《华尔街日报》的文章出来后，电视摄制组涌向了银溪。但蒂姆消失了。FBI分析了他的笔迹。他们按照他的炭疽手册上的说明进行操作，发现它们粗制滥造且不完整。他们得出结论：蒂姆·托比亚森是无辜的。由于媒体的曝光，蒂姆被全美各地的枪展禁入。他在银溪的邻居们说，他们不指望他回来，这最好，因为小镇不再欢迎他了。
I was feeling guilty. Tim was one of those guys who always lived in fear that the federal government would come after him. And John and I made his paranoid fantasy come true. I called the FBI. I wanted to know if the hounding of the innocent Tim Tobiason was all because of me and John. The clerk I spoke to said, Michael couldn't come to the phone, he was too busy.
我感到内疚。蒂姆就是那种总是生活在对联邦政府上门的恐惧中的人。而约翰和我让他的偏执幻想成真了。我打给FBI。我想知道对无辜的蒂姆·托比亚森的追捕是否全是因为我和约翰。我交谈的那位办事员说，迈克尔接不了电话，他太忙了。
I felt like the rat on the cop shows, forced to squeal and then hung out to dry. But nobody forced me to squeal. The clerk told me that the FBI had been tipped off about Tim by a number of people, including undercover informants at gun shows. So maybe Tim's downfall was that he was too chatty with strangers. Maybe, despite his fear of informants, he was just so lonely for a sympathetic ear that he was willing to take his chances.
我觉得自己就像警察剧里的告密者，被迫吐露实情然后被过河拆桥。但没有人强迫我告密。办事员告诉我，FBI曾接到过关于蒂姆的举报，举报人包括枪展上的卧底线人。所以也许蒂姆的倒台是因为他对陌生人太健谈了。也许，尽管他害怕线人，但他太渴望得到一个同情的倾听者，以至于愿意冒险。
In retrospect, I feel embarrassed for the part I played in the whole thing. I guess no one wants to be a bystander to history anymore. We all want to have speaking roles. And now I've got a speaking role. I'm one of the guys who caught the guy who was almost the anthrax guy.
回想起来，我对自己在这整件事中扮演的角色感到尴尬。我想，再也没有人愿意做历史的旁观者了。我们都想有台词。现在我有台词了。我是那些抓住了那个差点成为“炭疽男”的人中的一员。
The week I called the feds, a woman in Oregon called the cops to report a white powder all over her car, a white powder which turned out to be pollen. The publisher of the Yankton Daily Press in Sioux Falls called the FBI because of a dust-like substance in the office. You know what it was? Dust.
在我给联邦政府打电话的那周，俄勒冈州的一名女子报案称她的车上全是白色粉末，那种粉末后来被证实是花粉。南达科他州苏瀑市《扬克顿每日新闻》（Yankton Daily Press）的发行人给FBI打了电话，因为办公室里有灰尘状物质。你知道那是什么吗？灰尘。
It seems crazy now, and maybe a little self-aggrandizing, for so many people, including me, to imagine ourselves at the heart of the intrigue. But it's easy to forget the mood of the time. A feeling of hysteria took over, which made all these actions make sense. And then the hysteria just vanished away again. For a while, it felt like anything could happen. It's hard to say which is harder to figure out, how it all became such a frenzy, or how it's all come to feel like so long ago so soon. We'd all like to believe that, in a crisis, we'll be the ones who act calmly and rationally. Some of us have a harder time believing that now.
现在看来很疯狂，也许还有点自大，有那么多人，包括我，把自己想象成阴谋的核心。但很容易忘记当时的情绪。歇斯底里的感觉占据了上风，这让所有这些行动都显得合情合理。然后歇斯底里又消失了。有一段时间，感觉什么都可能发生。很难说哪个更难理解：这一切是如何变得如此狂热，或者这一切是如何在这么短的时间内就变得如此遥远。我们都愿意相信，在危机中，我们会是冷静和理性行事的人。我们中有些人现在更难相信这一点了。
Jon Ronson is the author of the book Them: Adventures with Extremists.
乔恩·罗森是《他们：与极端分子冒险》（Them: Adventures with Extremists）一书的作者。
[MUSIC - "DUST IN THE WIND" BY KANSAS]
[音乐 - 堪萨斯合唱团的《尘归尘》（Dust in the Wind）]
Act Two, One Crucible Leads to Another. When people start naming names, it's like any other political act. Everybody involved starts to believe their own version of the truth.
第二章，《一个磨难引向另一个》。当人们开始“指名道姓”时，就像任何其他政治行为一样。每一个参与其中的人都开始相信自己版本的真相。
In their memoirs, the playwright Arthur Miller and the director Elia Kazan each tell this story about a conversation that they had back in 1952 when Kazan was called before the House Un-American Activities Committee. At the time, Miller and Kazan had been friends and coworkers. They'd known each other for years. Kazan was the director of Arthur Miller's play Death of a Salesman. In this case, however, their stories do not exactly match up.
在回忆录中，剧作家阿瑟·米勒（Arthur Miller）和导演伊利亚·卡赞（Elia Kazan）各自讲述了1952年他们两人进行过的一次谈话，当时卡赞被传唤到众议院非美活动调查委员会前。那时，米勒和卡赞是朋友兼同事。他们认识多年。卡赞是阿瑟·米勒的剧作《推销员之死》（Death of a Salesman）的导演。然而在这种情况下，他们的叙述并不完全吻合。
The committee, of course, was looking for the names of Communists. Kazan had been a party member briefly in the 1930s. And at first, he refused to name names. Then he relented. He wanted to talk to Miller about his testimony. Arthur Miller says that they talked after Kazan had already told the Committee the names of friends and coworkers who had been Communists. Kazan said they talked before he had given that testimony. And there are other differences.
委员会当然是在寻找共产党员的名字。卡赞在20世纪30年代曾短暂入党。起初，他拒绝“指名道姓”。后来他妥协了。他想和米勒谈谈他的证词。阿瑟·米勒说，他们谈话时，卡赞已经向委员会提供了那些曾是共产党员的朋友和同事的名字。卡赞则说他们谈话是在他给出那些证词之前。还有其他的分歧。
Here's Kazan's version first. In his autobiography, he has this passage that he says comes from his diary in the spring of 1952.
首先是卡赞的版本。在他的自传中，有这样一段话，他说这是来自他在1952年春天的日记。
"Conversation with Art Miller in the woods back of my home. I mentioned that Skouras--" Skouras is a studio head-- "had implied that I couldn't work in pictures anymore if I didn't name the other lefties in the group. Then I told Art I'd prepared myself for a period of no movie work or money, that I was prepared to face this if it was worthwhile, but that I didn't feel altogether good about such a decision, that I'd say to myself, what the hell am I giving all this up for? To defend a secrecy that I didn't think right? And to defend people who had already been named or soon would be named by someone else?
“与阿特·米勒（Art Miller）在我家后的树林里谈话。我提到斯库拉斯（Skouras）——”斯库拉斯是一位制片厂负责人——“暗示如果我不指名小组里的其他左翼分子，我就不能再拍电影了。然后我告诉阿特，我已经准备好面对一段没有电影工作或金钱的时期，如果值得的话，我准备面对这一点，但我对这样的决定并不完全感到好受，我会对自己说，我到底是为了什么放弃这一切？为了捍卫一个我认为不正确的秘密？为了捍卫那些已经被别人点名或很快就会被别人点名的人？”
"I said, I'd hated the Communists for many years and didn't feel right about giving up my career to defend them, that I would give up my film career if it was in the interest of defending something I believed in, but not this. Art said that it would be a personal disaster for him if I was run out of pictures. He hoped that it would not happen. He could see that it would concern me deeply. I only had to consider this, was I sacrificing for something that I believed in?
“我说，我憎恨共产党多年了，为捍卫他们而放弃事业觉得不值，如果捍卫我信仰的东西，我会放弃电影事业，但不是这个。阿特说如果我被赶出电影圈，对他来说将是一场个人灾难。他希望这不会发生。他看得出这让我深受困扰。我只需要考虑这一点：我是不是在为我所信仰的东西做出牺牲？”
"I didn't believe in the secret membership of the Communists. I'd fought it when I was a member. I then told Art how I'd been pushed to resign from the party. Art and I had never been frank about the Communist business.
“我不相信共产党人的秘密成员身份。我做成员时就反对它。然后我告诉阿特我是如何被逼退党的。阿特和我从未坦诚地谈过共产主义的事情。”
This was as much my fault as his and as much his as mine. But mainly, it was that nobody asked if his friend was a Communist in these days. Art never offered to tell me. He knew I was anti-Communist, but I'd always refrained from what I considered to be red-baiting.
“这既是我的错也是他的错。但主要是因为在这些日子里，没有人会问他的朋友是不是共产党员。阿特从没主动告诉我。他知道我反共，但我一直克制自己不去进行我认为是‘抹红’的行为。”
Art went on about the political situation. He said I was naive. We talked for 3/4 of an hour. He looked terribly worried. Walking back to the house, just before we came in view of the other people, he stopped and put his arm around me in his awkward way, the side of his body against mine, and said, 'Don't worry about what I'll think. Whatever you do will be OK with me, because I know your heart is in the right place.'
“阿特继续谈论政治局势。他说我太天真了。我们谈了45分钟。他看起来非常担心。走回房子，就在我们快要被其他人看到之前，他停下来，以他笨拙的方式搂住我，身体紧贴着我，说：‘别担心我会怎么想。不管你做什么，我都不会介意，因为我知道你的心是在正确位置上的。’”
"I was surprised by the phrase, and, as soon as I could, wrote it down. 'Your heart is in the right place.' It was like the truth in a pop song title. There was no doubt that Art meant it and that he was anxious to say this to me before we separated. We parted on affectionate terms."
“我被这个说法惊到了，一有机会就把它记了下来。‘你的心是在正确位置上的。’这就像流行歌名里的真相。毫无疑问，阿特是认真的，而且在分手前他急于对我这么说。我们怀着深情分开了。”
Well, Arthur Miller's account of the story appears in his autobiography. His account is a bit longer than Kazan's. And we asked actor Richard Henzel to read an edited version for us. Here it is.
好吧，阿瑟·米勒对这件事的叙述出现在他的自传中。他的叙述比卡赞的要长一些。我们请演员理查德·亨泽尔（Richard Henzel）为我们读了一个删减版本。内容如下。
"The day before I was to leave, Kazan phoned and asked to see me. Since he was not a man to idly chat, at least not with me, and since this was his second or third such call in the past few weeks, I began to suspect that something terrible had come to him and that it must be the committee. I drove into a dun and rainy Connecticut morning in early April 1952, cursing the time. For I all but knew that my friend would tell me he had decided to cooperate with the committee. Though he had passed through the party for a brief period 15 years before, as he had once mentioned to me, I knew that he had no particular political life anymore, at least not in the five years of our acquaintance. I found my anger rising, and not against him, whom I loved like a brother, but against the committee.
“在我离开的前一天，卡赞打来电话要求见我。因为他不是一个会闲聊的人，至少跟我不是，而且这是他在过去几周里第二次或第三次打来这样的电话，我开始怀疑他遇上了什么糟糕的事，那一定是委员会的事。1952年4月初一个阴冷多雨的康涅狄格州早晨，我开车过去，咒骂着时间。因为我几乎知道我的朋友会告诉我，他已经决定与委员会合作了。尽管他在15年前曾经历过短暂的入党期，就像他曾对我提起过的那样，但我知道，在我认识他的五年里，他已经没什么具体的政治生活了。我感到愤怒升腾，不是针对他，我像兄弟一样爱他，而是针对委员会。”
"The sun briefly appeared, and we left his house to walk in the woods under dripping branches, amid the odor of decay and regeneration that a long rain drives up from the earth in a cold country forest. The story-- simple and, by now, routine-- took but a moment to tell. He had been subpoenaed and had refused to cooperate, but had changed his mind and returned to testify fully in executive session, confirming some dozen names of people he had known in his months in the party so long ago. He was trying, I thought, to appear relieved in his mind. Actually, he wanted my advice, almost as though he had not yet done what he had done.
“太阳短暂地露面，我们离开他家走进树林，在滴水的树枝下散步，置身于寒冷的森林中那场漫长的雨从大地深处催发出的腐烂与新生的气息中。这个故事——简单，如今已是例行公事——只花了片刻就讲完了。他被传唤，曾拒绝配合，但改变了主意，又回去在执行会议上作了全面证词，证实了他多年前在党内几个月里认识的十几个人名。我想，他试图让自己显得心里释然。事实上，他想要我的建议，好像他还没有做他已经做过的事一样。”
"There was a certain gloomy logic in what he was saying. Unless he came clean, he could never hope, at the height of his creative powers, to make another film in America. And he had been told, in so many words, by his old boss and friend Spyros Skouras, president of 20th Century Fox, that the company would not employ him unless he satisfied the committee.
“他所说的话里有一种阴郁的逻辑。除非他把话说清楚，否则在他创作能力的巅峰时期，他别想在美利坚再拍一部电影了。而且他的老上司兼朋友、二十世纪福克斯公司的总裁斯皮罗斯·斯库拉斯（Spyros Skouras）已经明确告诉他，除非他满足委员会，否则公司将不再聘用他。”
"He spoke as factually as he could. And it was a quiet calamity opening before me in the woods, because I felt my sympathy going toward him, and, at the same time, I was afraid of him. I was growing cooler with the thought that, as unbelievable as it seemed, I could still be up for sacrifice if Kazan knew I had attended meetings for party writers years ago and had made a speech at one of them. Had I been of his generation, he would have had to sacrifice me as well. And finally, that was all I could think of. I could not get past it.
“他尽可能如实地陈述。那是一场在我眼前在树林里开启的寂静灾难，因为我感到我的同情心倾向他，但同时，我又害怕他。随着时间的推移，我越来越冷静地想到，尽管看起来不可思议，如果卡赞知道我多年前参加过党内作家的会议并在其中一次会议上发过言，我也可能会成为牺牲品。如果我和他是一代人，他也必须牺牲我。最终，我只能想到这一点。我无法跨过它。”
"I felt a silence rising around me, an impending and invisible wash of dulled vibrations between us, like an endless moaning musical note through which we could not hear or speak anymore. It was sadness, purely mournful, deadening. And it had been done to us. Who or what was now safer because this man, in his human weakness, had been forced to humiliate himself?
“我感到寂静在我周围升起，一种即将到来的、无形的、沉闷的震动波在我们之间冲刷，像一种无尽的、呜咽的音符，透过它我们再也听不清或说不出话来。那是纯粹的悲哀、哀伤，令人麻木。这一切都是被施加在我们身上的。既然这个人因为人性的软弱被迫自取其辱，那谁或什么东西现在就更安全了呢？”
"As I got into my car to leave, Molly Kazan came out of the house into the drizzle that had begun again. She could tell, I suppose, that it had not gone well. It was impossible to keep looking into her distraught eyes. I was half inside the car when Molly came out and asked, unforgettably, if I realized that the United Electrical Workers Union was entirely in the hands of Communists. Then she pointed out toward the road and told me that I no longer understood the country, that everybody who lived on that road approved of the committee and what had been done. I didn't know what to say anymore across the crevasse widening between us.
“当我坐上车准备离开时，莫莉·卡赞（Molly Kazan）从房子里走出来，走进了再次开始的小雨中。我想她看得出谈话不顺利。盯着她心烦意乱的眼睛看是不可能的。我半个身子还在车里，莫莉出来问了一个让我难忘的问题：我是否意识到联合电气工人联盟（UE）完全在共产党的掌控之中？然后她指着路的方向告诉我，我已经不再了解这个国家了，住在那条路上的每个人都赞同委员会和所做的一切。在那道在我们之间不断扩宽的裂缝中，我已不知该说什么了。”
"In the awkward pre-departure moment, after I had said that I could not agree with their decision, she asked if I was staying at my house, half an hour away. And I said that I was on my way to Salem. She instantly understood what my destination meant. And her eyes widened in sudden apprehension and, possibly, anger. 'You're not going to equate witches with this.' I told her, I wasn't at all sure I could write a play, but I was going to look into the stuff they had up there. We all waved rather grimly as I pulled away.
“在那个尴尬的临别时刻，在我说过我无法同意他们的决定之后，她问我是否住在半小时车程外的家里。我说我在去塞勒姆（Salem）的路上。她瞬间明白了我的目的地意味着什么。她的眼睛因为突然的忧虑和可能出现的愤怒而睁大。‘你不会把巫婆和这事画等号吧。’我告诉她，我完全不确定能不能写一部剧，但我打算去看看他们在那里发现的东西。我们有些阴郁地挥了挥手，我就开车离开了。”
"Once on the road, nosing the car north, I thought, she was probably right about the people in the comfortable homes I was passing, and felt myself drifting beyond the pale. The strangeness was sharper because, as usual, I was carrying several contradictions at the same time, my brother love, as painfully alive in me as it had ever been, alongside the undeniable fact that Kazan might have sacrificed me had it been necessary."
“车子开上路向北，我想，关于我经过的那些舒适住宅里的人，她可能是对的。我感到自己正漂流出文明之外。那种陌生感更加尖锐，因为像往常一样，我同时承载着几个矛盾：我的兄弟情谊，一如既往地在我心中生动存在，同时还有一个不可否认的事实，即如果必要的话，卡赞可能会牺牲我。”
Miller concludes this passage in his biography this way. "In a sense, I went naked to Salem," he writes, "still unable to accept the most common experience of humanity, the shifts of interest that turned loving husbands and wives into stony enemies, loving parents into indifferent supervisors or even exploiters of their own children and so forth. As I already knew from my reading, that was the real story of ancient Salem Village, what they called then the breaking of charity with one another."
米勒在他的自传中这样总结这段内容。“从某种意义上说，我是赤身裸体去塞勒姆的，”他写道，“仍然无法接受人类最普遍的体验，即那些将恩爱的夫妻变成顽固敌人的利益转移，将慈爱的父母变成冷漠的管理者甚至压榨自己孩子的剥削者等等。正如我从阅读中早已知道的那样，那才是古代塞勒姆村的真实故事，他们当时称之为‘与彼此断绝慈善’。”
Miller, of course, did go on to write The Crucible about the Salem witch trials. In that play, John Proctor is the hero who prefers to die rather than give false testimony.
米勒当然继续写了关于塞勒姆女巫审判的《炼狱》（The Crucible）。在那部戏里，约翰·普罗克特（John Proctor）是那位宁死也不愿给出虚假证词的英雄。
Around the same time, Kazan went on to direct the film On The Waterfront. In that film, Marlon Brando plays a hero who makes the principled decision to testify against the mob. It is, many have said, the most eloquent defense for squealing on film, though in later years, Kazan said that he simply wanted to demonstrate the moral ambiguity of this kind of situation, that it is not black and white.
大约在同一时间，卡赞执导了电影《码头风云》（On The Waterfront）。在那部电影中，马龙·白兰度（Marlon Brando）饰演了一位英雄，做出了告发黑帮的原则性决定。许多人说，这是电影中最有力的告密辩护，尽管在后来的几年里，卡赞说他只是想展示这种处境的道德模糊性，即它并非非黑即白。
One thing you've got to understand, Father. On the dock, we've always been D and D.
有一件事你必须明白，神父。在码头上，我们一直都是“聋哑”（D and D）。
D and D, what's that?
“聋哑”，那是什么？
Deaf and dumb. No matter how much we hate the torpedoes, we don't rat.
“耳聋口哑”。不管我们多么憎恨那些鱼雷（torpedoes，指黑帮打手），我们从不告密。
Rat? Oh boys, get smart. I know you're getting pushed around. But there's one thing we've got in this country, and that's ways of fighting back. Now getting the facts to the public, testifying for what you know is right against what you know is wrong. Now what's ratting to them is telling the truth for you. Now can't you see that? Can't you see that? Huh?
告密？噢孩子们，聪明点。我知道你们正被欺负。但我们在这个国家拥有一件事，那就是反击的方法。把事实公之于众，为了你明辨的是非黑白而为正义作证。现在，在他们看来是告密的行为，对你来说是在说真话。现在难道你们看不出来吗？难道你们看不出来吗？嗯？
Coming up, the breaking of charity with one another in one small town in Tennessee. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来的节目，田纳西州一个小镇中“与彼此断绝慈善”的故事。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Naming Names, stories of people turning in friends, and coworkers, and strangers, I guess  too, to the government. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Beating the Erasers. This next story takes place in a small town in Tennessee, a town so small, in fact, that it has just one elementary school, which is where most of this story takes place. Susan Drury tells the tale.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“指名道姓”，关于人们把朋友、同事甚至陌生人告发给政府的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第三章。第三章，《击败橡皮擦的人》。下一个故事发生田纳西州的一个小镇，一个小到甚至只有一所小学的小镇，大部分故事就发生在那里。苏珊·德鲁里（Susan Drury）讲述了这个故事。
If you spend a little time in Spring Hill, Tennessee, you will start to wonder who Noel Evans was. There's Evans Park, named for him and his wife Jerry. And the main drag through town has a sign next to it, saying that it's sponsored by friends of Noel and Jerry Evans. And people talk about him fondly.
如果你在田纳西州的斯普林希尔（Spring Hill）待上一段时间，你会开始想知道诺埃尔·埃文斯（Noel Evans）是谁。这里有埃文斯公园，以他和妻子杰瑞（Jerry）的名字命名。穿过小镇的主干道旁边有一个标志，写着它是由诺埃尔和杰瑞·埃文斯的朋友赞助的。人们亲切地谈论着他。
They talk about the competent and kind way he ran the local elementary school for decades, the way he taught new generations of local children and parents. They tell stories of what a dream he was to work for, how he supported teachers in contract negotiations and with difficult parents, how he brought staff and friends tomatoes and peas from his garden, and how he brought some lucky few the peach pies his wife made. Many people, dozens of people, told me that they had never heard him raise his voice. And a similar number told me they looked up to him as a father figure.
他们谈论他几十年来经营当地小学的方式，那样的胜任与仁慈，他教育了当地一代又一代的孩子和家长。他们讲述在他手下工作是多么美妙，他如何在合同谈判中支持教师、如何应对难缠的家长、他如何从花园里给员工和朋友带去西红柿和豌豆、他又如何给一些幸运儿带来他妻子做的桃子派。许多人，几十个人，告诉我他们从未听过他提高嗓门。同样多的人告诉我，他们把他视为父亲般的长辈。
But there is one story about Noel Evans that people refer to, but rarely want to tell. People here disagree vehemently about the facts and the meaning of this story. The people I found who did want to talk about it, on both sides, mostly did not want to talk on tape. Many people, also on both sides, did not want their names used. And others did not want to talk at all. Because this is a story that severed families and decades-old friendships, and people aren't over it. It's the story of how, when a few people here decided to name names, it spun out of control immediately, taking over their lives, taking over the life of the man they accused, and ripping apart the town.
但关于诺埃尔·埃文斯，有一个人们会提到、但很少愿意讲述的故事。这里的人们对这个故事的事实和意义有着激烈的争执。我发现愿意谈论它的双方大部分人都不愿意录音。双方的许多人也不希望使用他们的名字。还有些人根本不想谈论。因为这是一个让家庭破碎、让几十年友谊破裂的故事，人们还没走出来。这是一个关于这里几个人决定“指名道姓”时，事情如何瞬间失控、夺走了他们的生活、夺走了他们所指控男子的生活，并撕裂了整个小镇的故事。
Here's how Wanda Wright tells the story. She had grown up in Spring Hill back in the '50s, when you could skate all the way down Main Street and get water at anybody's house because you knew them all. She had known Mr. Evans since she was a teenager. And he was her math teacher. She married the son of the man who had hired Evans. And some years later, Mr. Evans hired her to come back to Spring Hill and teach under him. Wanda knew everybody here. And she says she felt like she was just in the perfect town then, just totally surrounded by people she'd known forever. She was a true local, a total insider.
这就是万达·赖特（Wanda Wright）讲述的故事。她在50年代的斯普林希尔长大，当时你可以一直滑冰滑到大街上，去任何人家里讨水喝，因为大家都认识。她从十几岁起就认识埃文斯先生。他是她的数学老师。她嫁给了那个聘请埃文斯的人的儿子。几年后，埃文斯先生请她回到斯普林希尔在他手下任教。万达认识这里的所有人。她说她觉得当时自己就像身处完美的城镇，完全被她一生都认识的人所包围。她是真正的本地人，绝对的圈内人。
This was still a small town in 1994, when Mr. Evans told Wanda Wright that his strawberries were on their last legs, and if she wanted any, she should come pick them after school because he was about to plow them under. She dropped by, picked the berries, and went into the house for a minute with Mr. Evans. Suddenly, everything changed.
1994年，这仍然是一个小镇，当时埃文斯先生告诉万达·赖特他的草莓快不行了，如果她想要的话，应该放学后来摘，因为他准备把它们犁掉。她顺路去摘了草莓，和埃文斯先生进屋待了一会儿。突然间，一切都变了。
Evans asked her for a hug. They had hugged at school, but this was different. "He had this real weird, dark look in his eyes," said Wright. Something was definitely wrong. Wanda pulled her arms up under her chin and leaned over as he hugged her.
埃文斯向她索要拥抱。他们在学校拥抱过，但这次不同。“他眼神里有一种非常奇怪、阴暗的东西，”赖特说。肯定出问题了。万达把双臂缩在下巴下面，在他拥抱她时侧过身。
"I have to go," she said. But he was standing between her and the door. Then he asked her to kiss him. This was not a man she expected this of. He was her boss, but it went beyond that. "It was like your preacher, or your daddy, or something like that," she said.
“我得走了，”她说。但他站在她和门之间。然后他让她吻他。她没料到这个男人会这样。他是她的老板，但这超过了那个范围。“就像你的牧师，或者你的爸爸，诸如此类，”她说。
So the day after the incident at the house, Wanda says, Mr. Evans came to her classroom and gave her a fried peach pie and an apology. She threw the pie down on the desk like it was the worst thing she had ever seen. "We have to talk," said Wright. Wright told him she was going to have to leave the school.
就在屋里那件事发生的第二天，万达说，埃文斯先生来到她的教室，给了她一个油炸桃子派并道歉。她把派摔在桌子上，仿佛那是她见过的最糟糕的东西。“我们要谈谈，”赖特说。赖特告诉他，她不得不离开学校了。
Mr. Evans was totally apologetic. He said he didn't know what came over him. He swore it had never happened before, never, and it never would again. She told him if it ever happened again, she would report him. But that otherwise, she would not tell anyone.
埃文斯先生非常抱歉。他说他不知道自己是怎么了。他发誓这以前从未发生过，绝没有，以后也不会再发生了。她告诉他，如果再发生，她就会举报他。但除此之外，她不会告诉任何人。
He asked for her forgiveness, and she gave it to him. "Let's forget it," she said. "It's over." And she didn't exactly forget it. It made her edgy. But she wanted it to be over too. And they moved on. And on the surface, anyway, life at school pretty much returned to normal.
他请求原谅，她给了他。“忘掉它吧，”她说。“结束了。”她并没有完全忘掉它。这让她感到紧张。但她也想让它结束。他们继续前进。至少在表面上，学校的生活基本上恢复了正常。
Then three years later, in 1997, on a teacher workday, when the kids were not at school, Mr. Evans, who lived near the school, invited everyone from the school down to his house during lunch time to see the indoor pool he and his wife had put in. Almost all the teachers went, but Wanda Wright did not. She had not returned to the house since the incident and was not going to go back, not even with a group.
然后三年后的1997年，在一个没有孩子上课的教师工作日，住在学校附近的埃文斯先生邀请全校师生午餐时间去他家看看他和妻子安装的室内游泳池。几乎所有老师都去了，但万达·赖特没去。自那件事发生以来，她再没回过那个房子，也不打算回去，即使是大家一起。
So she was doing some work in her classroom when Julia Priest came in. Julia was a guidance counselor at the school. "Why didn't you go down to Mr. Evans'?" Wanda asked Julia. "Why didn't you go?" Julia shot back. They looked at each other, and, without either of them saying a word, they both realized they were keeping the same secret about Mr. Evans.
所以她正在教室里工作，朱莉娅·普里斯特（Julia Priest）进来了。朱莉娅是学校的指导顾问。“你为什么没去埃文斯先生家？”万达问朱莉娅。“你为什么没去？”朱莉娅反问。他们互相对视，无需多言，两人都意识到他们保守着关于埃文斯先生同样的秘密。
Julia told Wanda Wright that, in 1994, Mr. Evans had approached her in her office. She thought he was going to hug her. But instead, he grabbed her and rubbed himself on her two times. She had told two friends about it at the time, one of whom urged her to report it to a supervisor, which she did, though nothing ever came of it. On the day it happened, she was wearing a fuchsia, striped dress with a teal color and matching fuchsia shoes. "We used to coordinate like that," she says. She burned the clothes.
朱莉娅告诉万达·赖特，1994年，埃文斯先生曾在办公室接近她。她以为他要拥抱她。但相反，他抓住她，在他身上蹭了两次。当时她把这事告诉了两个朋友，其中一人催促她向主管举报，她确实做了，尽管什么都没发生。在那件事发生的当天，她穿着一件紫红色条纹、带有青色装饰的裙子，配着紫红色的鞋子。“我们过去经常那样搭配，”她说。她把那件衣服烧了。
She wanted to change schools, and kept her eye out for other jobs. But she thought she could just manage it, stay a safe distance away, keep her hand on the doorknob whenever they were meeting together. And she had made it work well enough. Nothing had ever happened again. And she had thought she was the only one. Wanda told Julia her story too. And again, they believed that they were the only two teachers this had happened to.
她想换学校，并留意其他工作。但她认为自己能应付，保持安全距离，每次见面时手都放在门把手上。她处理得还行。什么也没再发生过。她还以为只有她一个。万达也把自己的故事告诉了朱莉娅。她们再次认为她们只是两个被这件事影响到的老师。
Then a few months later, a younger teacher called Wanda to confide in her that Mr. Evans was coming to her house, that he had hit on her, that she was afraid of him. Then Wanda and Julia started to wonder about Susan Nelson, a second grade teacher who seemed to steer clear of Mr. Evans. Wanda asked Susan, "Did Mr. Evans ever make a pass at you?" Susan Nelson was stunned at the question. She hadn't even told her husband. She said yes.
几个月后，一位更年轻的老师打电话给万达，向她吐露埃文斯先生曾到她家，曾骚扰她，她很怕他。于是万达和朱莉娅开始怀疑苏珊·尼尔森（Susan Nelson），一位似乎刻意避开埃文斯先生的二年级老师。万达问苏珊：“埃文斯先生有没有调戏过你？”苏珊·尼尔森对这个问题感到震惊。她甚至没告诉她丈夫。她说有。
Now it started to look like there was a much bigger problem at the school. But they weren't sure what to do about it. Up until this point, they had all tried to deal with the problem face-to-face, without getting outsiders or the bigger bureaucracy involved. Wanda had confronted Mr. Evans in person, one-on-one, the way you do with someone you've known so long, when they step over the line or when they hurt you. The women talked about getting Mr. Evans some help or together confronting him in some way. They all say they didn't want to report him. Reporting him just seemed like it would unleash some process that would just blow everybody up.
现在看来学校里有一个大得多的问题。但她们不知道该怎么办。直到目前为止，她们都试图面对面解决问题，不涉及外人或更大的官僚机构。万达就像你面对一个认识很久、越界或伤害你的人那样，亲自面对过埃文斯先生。女士们谈论过让埃文斯先生得到些帮助，或者一起找他当面对质。她们都说她们不想举报他。举报他似乎会引发某种会让每个人都炸锅的程序。
They ended up turning him in by accident. Wanda confided in a friend who was also the school's vice principal. And because she was a vice principal, a supervisor, she was compelled by school policy to report what she had heard. And so a few days later, Human Resources staffers were at Spring Hill Elementary, calling selected teachers in and asking them questions about sexual harassment at the school.
她们最终是意外地举报了他。万达向一位也是学校副校长的朋友吐露了心声。因为她是副校长、主管，根据学校政策，她被迫报告她听到的事情。几天后，人力资源部人员出现在斯普林希尔小学，传唤选定的老师并询问她们关于学校性骚扰的问题。
When they brought Wanda Wright to the conference room and she saw the questions, she walked to the corner of the conference room and just slid down the wall, bawling. It took her a full week before she agreed to answer the questions. It was one of the hardest decisions she ever had to make in her life. She was terrified of doing something that she knew would destroy this man who she still had some respect for. And she, like Julia and Susan, they're private.
当他们把万达·赖特带到会议室看到那些问题时，她走到会议室角落沿着墙滑了下去，号啕大哭。整整一周，她才同意回答这些问题。这是她一生中做过的最艰难的决定之一。她很害怕做出一件她知道会毁掉这个她仍存有敬意的男人。而且她，像朱莉娅和苏珊一样，她们很内向。
Even when I wanted to interview them about this story, they were incredibly reluctant. And though they ultimately decided to talk to me, they didn't want to have their voices on the radio. "It's too intimate," they said. In the end, Wanda decided she could not lie and make the other women look like liars.
即使我想采访她们这个故事，她们也非常抗拒。虽然最终决定告诉我，但她们不想让自己的声音上广播。“太私密了，”她们说。最终，万达决定她不能撒谎，让其他女性看起来像骗子。
That's how Wanda, Susan, and Julia tell the story, how they told it to me. Noel Evans denied all the allegations against him. In each case, he denied that he ever kissed, or groped, or grabbed the women, and emphasized how close he was to each of them, how friendly they were to him, and how easy it would be for people to misinterpret his actions. For instance, he wrote that Wanda was in his house, and that before she left with the berries, he gave her a fatherly hug "like I give my daughter on the rare occasions I get to see her."
这就是万达、苏珊和朱莉娅讲述故事的方式，也就是她们告诉我的方式。诺埃尔·埃文斯否认了所有针对他的指控。在每一种情况下，他都否认自己曾亲吻、猥亵或抓住过这些女性，并强调他和每个人有多亲近、她们对他有多友好，以及人们误解他的行为是多么容易。例如，他写道万达在他家里，在离开去拿草莓之前，他给了她一个父亲般的拥抱，“就像我偶尔见到女儿时那样。”
About a week after the women were questioned and Evans was removed from the school without explanation, the director of schools officially announced that the administration was investigating instances of alleged sexual harassment at the school. Richard Roach from the school board.
在这些女性受到问讯、埃文斯在没有解释的情况下被从学校调离大约一周后，学区主管正式宣布政府正在调查学校涉嫌性骚扰的案件。学区董事会的理查德·罗奇（Richard Roach）。
I heard about it by watching the 6 o'clock news. Then of course, immediately the phone started ringing. While the broadcast was going on, the phone started ringing. And it got so bad, we couldn't eat supper. We could not, literally, eat supper. Because the moment people got in, they'd see the headline from that day, or the rumor would come through, and they'd start calling.
我是通过看6点的新闻听说的。当然，电话立刻开始响了。广播还在进行时，电话就开始响了。情况变得很糟糕，我们晚饭都吃不下。我们简直无法吃晚饭。因为人们一进来，看到当天的头条新闻，或者谣言传开，他们就开始打进电话。
People here knew this man. They did not, it seems, have reservations about him. He'd been at the school for over 30 years. And most people did not believe that Evans was a sexual harasser. And even the women, themselves, said that they, themselves, would not have believed it either if it hadn't actually happened to them. Again, Richard Roach from the school board.
这里的人认识这个男人。看起来，他们对他没有疑虑。他在学校待了30多年。大多数人并不相信埃文斯是性骚扰者。即便这些女士自己也说，如果不是亲身经历，她们自己也不会相信。再次引用学区董事会的理查德·罗奇的话。
I can't remember one single phone call that was anti-Noel Evans. I think anybody that had that point of view was pretty well afraid to speak up, because you were outnumbered 30:1. They thought, this is a witch hunt. He's being railroaded. He's being accused of things he didn't do. One woman called me, and she said, my children are in Spring Hill. I went to Spring Hill. My mother went to school under him. I have known him since I was four years old. And she was so mad. She was just almost incoherent, she was so mad, crying, upset.
我不记得有任何一个电话是反对诺埃尔·埃文斯的。我认为任何持这种观点的人都相当害怕说出来，因为你的比例是1:30。他们想，这是一场猎巫行动。他被冤枉了。他被指控做了一些他没做的事。一个女人打电话给我，她说，我的孩子在斯普林希尔。我在斯普林希尔上学。我母亲也是在他手下上的学。我从四岁就认识他了。她非常生气。她生气到几乎语无伦次，在哭，很难过。
A lot of people were mad, not at Evans, at his accusers. And even though some of the names of the accusers weren't officially released, many teachers and some townspeople started to figure out who was involved. The actual allegations against Evans weren't public just yet. It was all sort of vague, what he was accused of. And in trying to piece the story together, to understand it, a lot of people decided to believe that Mr. Evans did nothing wrong, but that maybe the women misunderstood or misinterpreted his behavior.
很多人都很生气，不是对埃文斯，而是对他的指控者。虽然一些指控者的名字还没正式公布，许多老师和一些镇民开始查出是谁参与其中了。针对埃文斯的实际指控还未公开。对他被指控的内容都很含糊。在拼凑这个故事、试图理解它的时候，很多人决定相信埃文斯先生没做错事，也许是这些女士误解或曲解了他的行为。
When the women described what had happened to friends or family, they got some pretty mixed reactions. A friend asked one of the women, "Well, what did he do to you? Did he rape you?" Informed of what Mr. Evans had done, the friend said, "Is that all?" Richard Roach was typical of most people in town.
当女士们向朋友或家人描述发生的事情时，她们得到了一些相当复杂的反应。一个朋友问其中一位女士：“好吧，他把你怎么样了？他强奸你了吗？”告知了埃文斯先生所做的事情后，朋友说：“就这些？”理查德·罗奇在镇上是大多数人的典型代表。
I never thought it was true. He may have used some bad judgment. Now I know a lot of people, especially the teachers involved, are going to get upset with me saying that. People's perceptions, things can happen, and they may perceive something happening that didn't, in fact, happen. But my first thought and my last thought was that he was innocent. And I will stand by that.
我从来不认为那是真的。他可能判断力有些失误。现在我知道许多人，特别是涉及的老师们，听到我这么说会很不高兴。人们的看法，事情可能会发生，她们可能会感觉到发生了什么，而事实上并没有发生。但我最初和最后的想法都是他是无辜的。我会坚持这一点。
Some people concluded that the women had more sinister motives. They believed that the women had plotted to destroy Noel Evans, either to get his job or to bring him down for other reasons. But here's something you have to know about the teachers. They didn't have anything to tag them as suspicious or unworthy of belief. They weren't known as gossips or troublemakers. They all had good reputations as teachers, and were all religious, middle-aged, married ladies with kids. And all of them had history and ties in this community too. And Wanda Wright's ties were the deepest. One Evan's supporter said to me, "Wanda was the real kicker, because she was the salt of the earth. But Mr. Evans, well, he was the core of the salt of the earth."
有些人断定这些女性有更险恶的动机。他们相信这些女性密谋摧毁诺埃尔·埃文斯，要么是为了得到他的工作，要么是因为其他原因把他拉下马。但关于这些老师，有些事你必须知道。她们身上没有任何可疑或不值得信任的标签。她们没有流言蜚语或制造麻烦的名声。她们作为老师都有很好的名声，而且都是虔诚、中年、已婚并有孩子的女士。她们所有人也在这个社区里有历史和联系。万达·赖特的联系最深。一位埃文斯的支持者对我说：“万达才是真正的冲击，因为她是大地之盐。但埃文斯先生，嗯，他是大地之盐的核心。”
So people had to make a choice, a terrible choice, a choice about who to believe. If you believed the women, everything you knew was turned upside down. So people chose to believe him. One teacher said that her belief in Mr. Evans' character was so strong that nothing could change it. "If a man walked into the school and Mr. Evans shot him," she said, "then I know the man deserved to be shot."
所以人们不得不做出选择，一个可怕的选择，一个关于相信谁的选择。如果你相信这些女性，你所知道的一切都颠倒了。所以人们选择相信他。一位老师说，她对埃文斯先生人格的信念如此坚定，以至于什么都无法改变它。“如果一个男人走进学校，而埃文斯先生射杀了他，”她说，“那我知道那个男人罪有应得。”
The atmosphere at the school became very tense. Many teachers started wearing yellow ribbons to show their support for Noel Evans. Wanda went to the cafeteria one day, and some of the workers walked off the line, refusing to serve her. One person told Julia Priest that some of the teachers were praying that Priest and the other accusers would literally go to hell to suffer for their lies.
学校里的气氛变得非常紧张。许多老师开始佩戴黄丝带以表示对诺埃尔·埃文斯的支持。有一天万达去餐厅，一些工人在打饭线上走开，拒绝为她服务。一个人告诉朱莉娅·普里斯特，一些老师在祈祷普里斯特和其他指控者下地狱，为她们的谎言受苦。
It was such a frightening climate that every day, as Wanda Wright left the school, she looked under her car before she got in, making sure there was nobody there to attack her. Then once she got in the car, she'd pause for a minute before she turned the key, half expecting the car to explode.
这是一个令人恐惧的环境，每天万达·赖特离开学校时，她都要在进去前检查车下，确保没人攻击她。然后一旦进入车内，她会在转动钥匙前停顿一分钟，半预料着车子会爆炸。
In a sense, both sides felt they were victims of a witch hunt, Evans, who said his actions were being misinterpreted, and the women, who said they were being persecuted for telling the truth of what happened to them. Maybe this is what always happens. Noel Evans retired on May 22, 1997. He made a settlement with the district that he would get his full retirement benefits and that the investigation file would not be public.
从某种意义上说，双方都觉得自己是猎巫行动的受害者，埃文斯说他的行为被曲解了，而女士们说她们因为讲述事实而受到迫害。也许这就是永远会发生的事情。诺埃尔·埃文斯于1997年5月22日退休。他与学区达成和解，获得全额退休福利，且调查文件不对外公开。
He was offered and accepted a big job as the leader of the Tennessee Retired Teachers Association. Lots of people saw him as a good man who had been run off. And they were sad to see him go. Then, two months later, Noel Evans shot his wife and then himself to death.
他获得并接受了一份大工作，担任田纳西州退休教师协会的领袖。很多人把他看作被赶走的好人。他们很遗憾看到他离开。然后，两个月后，诺埃尔·埃文斯射杀了他的妻子，随后自杀身亡。
Wanda, Julia, and Susan were horrified by the Evanses' deaths, like everyone else. But Julia also thought that more people might believe them now. They thought it would be clearer for people that something was and had been terribly wrong with Mr. Evans, something nobody could really understand. And I met people in town who changed their minds about Mr. Evans after the deaths. But for his core supporters, the people who knew him best, it only made them more certain.
万达、朱莉娅和苏珊像其他人一样对埃文斯夫妇的死亡感到震惊。但朱莉娅也认为现在可能有更多人相信她们了。她们认为人们会更清楚埃文斯先生身上有一些而且一直有一些极其糟糕的问题，一些没人能真正理解的东西。我确实遇到镇上有人在死亡事件后改变了对埃文斯先生的看法。但对于他的核心支持者，那些最了解他的人来说，这只会让他们更加确定。
Mr. Evans' supporters concluded that the deaths only proved how truly cruel, truly damaging the investigation had been to him. He had been falsely accused, removed from his school, lost his reputation, and look where it led him. And many of his supporters didn't believe he murdered his wife. They believe the stress and loss of honor to both Mr. And Mrs. Evans was so great that they had made an arrangement to die, a suicide pact. One teacher told me with tears in his voice, "They had a kind of love that modern people don't understand. They wanted to die together."
埃文斯先生的支持者断定，死亡事件只证明了调查对他来说是多么残酷、多么具有破坏性。他被诬告、被逐出学校、名誉扫地，看看这导致了什么后果。他的许多支持者不相信他谋杀了妻子。他们相信这种压力和埃文斯先生夫妇尊严的丧失如此巨大，以至于他们达成了死亡协议，一个自杀契约。一位老师含着泪对我说：“他们拥有一种现代人无法理解的爱。他们想一起死。”
This theory is a popular one. The chief of police was a family friend of the Evanses. And he put it into his official report on the crime. Although he notes that Mrs. Evans was in her pajamas, apparently sleeping on the couch when she was shot in the face by her husband, he still concludes it's a double suicide. Quote, "I simply do not believe he could have killed Jerry without a pact of some kind between them. I cannot see Noel taking Jerry's life without her agreeing to it. I think Noel and Jerry had worked it out, and Jerry told Noel, 'I cannot do myself. I do not want to know when it is going to happen.'" In big letters at the bottom of the page, the police chief writes, "God bless us all."
这种理论很流行。警察局长是埃文斯家的老友。他把它写进了关于这起犯罪的官方报告。虽然他注意到埃文斯夫人在被枪击中脸部时穿着睡衣，显然是在沙发上睡觉，但他仍得出结论是双重自杀。引用：“我根本不相信他能在没有某种契约的情况下杀死杰瑞。我看不出诺埃尔会在杰瑞不知情的情况下夺走她的生命。我认为诺埃尔和杰瑞已经商量好了，杰瑞对诺埃尔说：‘我不能自己动手。我不想知道什么时候会发生。’”在页面底部的页脚处，警察局长写道：“上帝保佑我们所有人。”
Other police investigators thought the chief's notes were wild and irresponsible. One veteran officer I spoke with who had been at the scene said, there was no evidence to support this idea of a double suicide, that this was one of the most gruesome and disturbing crime scenes he had seen in his years on the force, and that most of the investigators there concluded Mrs. Evans was murdered, plain and simple. Immediately after the deaths, people proposed to rename the elementary school after Noel Evans.
其他警察调查人员认为局长的记录既疯狂又不负责任。我交谈过的一位曾在现场的资深警官说，没有证据支持这种双重自杀的想法，这是他职业生涯中见过的最恐怖、最令人不安的犯罪现场之一，大多数调查人员认为埃文斯夫人是被谋杀的，简单明了。死亡事件后不久，人们提议用诺埃尔·埃文斯的名字命名这所小学。
There was something else people wanted. They wanted the names of the women who had accused Evans of harassment. At that point, the names hadn't been officially released. All most people had were rumors. Evans' supporters say, his good name meant everything to him, and the loss of his good name destroyed him. And so it was important to name the accusers, so that, somehow, they would lose their good names too. 10 days after the Evanses were found dead, the names of his accusers were all printed in the paper. Once the women were officially named, Evans' supporters circulated a petition to fire the director of schools and the women who made the allegations.
人们还想要别的东西。他们想要那些指控埃文斯性骚扰的女性的名字。在那时，名字尚未正式公布。大多数人只得到了谣言。埃文斯的支持者说，他的好名声对他来说就是一切，而好名声的丧失毁了他。因此，必须把指控者的名字指出来，这样以某种方式，她们的好名声也该丢掉。在埃文斯夫妇被发现死亡10天后，他的指控者名字全部登在了报纸上。一旦这些女性被正式点名，埃文斯的支持者就开始散发请愿书，要求解雇学区主管和那些进行指控的女性。
Mr. Chairman, members of the School Board, Maury County has recently witnessed the slow torture and destruction of Principal Noel Evans.
主席先生，学校董事会的成员们，莫里县（Maury County）最近目睹了校长诺埃尔·埃文斯的缓慢折磨和毁灭。
Here's Ray Williams, a local businessman and soon to be mayor, presenting the petitions to the School Board shortly after the names were released.
这是雷·威廉姆斯（Ray Williams），当地一位商人，不久后当选为市长，在名字公布后不久向学校董事会提交请愿书。
The director of schools has publicly attested to following School Board policies and procedures, as Maury Countyers have watched common sense go out the door. Who do you think will be the next victim of a school system in constant turmoil and fear?
学区主管公开证明遵循学校董事会的政策和程序，而莫里县民众眼睁睁看着常识被抛出窗外。你们认为在不断动荡和恐惧的学校系统中，下一个受害者会是谁？
As time passed, more women stepped forward to describe how Mr. Evans came on to them or their friends, so the women don't regret turning him in. They say what they learned from all this is that it doesn't matter what the facts are. People don't really want to know.
随着时间的推移，更多的女性站出来描述埃文斯先生是如何纠缠她们或她们的朋友的，所以女士们不后悔举报他。她们说从这件事中学到的是，事实是什么并不重要。人们根本不想知道真相。
Like Wanda says, she wouldn't have believed them either. She had known Mr. Evans for too long. It seemed too out of character. It was their good names against his good name. And in the end, he had a better name than they did. And so although the town decided not to name the elementary school after him, it did name the playground for him, and a scholarship fund, and a stretch of road as you come through town.
像万达说的，她自己也不会相信她们。她认识埃文斯先生太久了。这看起来太不符合他的性格了。那是她们的好名声对他的好名声。最终，他的名声比她们好。因此，尽管小镇决定不用他的名字命名小学，但确实用他的名字命名了操场、设立了奖学金基金，并用他名字命名了穿过小镇的一段公路。
This hasn't driven the women out. Susan Nelson still teaches music at the school, and Wanda Wright teaches the third grade. Julia Priest has a district-wide special ed job. They're tough. They've survived. And they have a heavily highlighted copy of Anita Hill's book that they've passed around. Many people still don't speak to them. And they still pause before having to introduce themselves at any function, watching for that flash of recognition when people hear their names.
这并没有赶走这些女士。苏珊·尼尔森仍然在学校教音乐，万达·赖特教三年级。朱莉娅·普里斯特有一份全学区的特殊教育工作。她们很坚强。她们活了下来。她们有一本安妮塔·希尔（Anita Hill）的书，上面画满了重点，她们互相传阅。许多人仍然不和她们说话。当她们在任何场合必须自我介绍时，她们仍然会停顿一下，观察当人们听到她们名字时那一闪而过的识别感。
Susan Drury in Tennessee.
苏珊·德鲁里在田纳西州。
Well, our program was produced today by Starlee Kine and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Jonathan Goldstein. Senior producer, Julie Snyder.
好吧，我们的节目今天由Starlee Kine和我本人制作，Alex Blumberg、Wendy Dorr和Jonathan Goldstein参与。高级制片人，Julie Snyder。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, whose new autobiography begins with this sentence.
WBEZ管理监督由Torey Malatia负责，他的新自传以这句话开始。
He stood apart, a lone wolf amongst lone wolves, a pasty-looking man wearing a lumberjack shirt and glasses.
他站在一边，是一个独行狼中的独行狼，一个脸色苍白、穿着伐木工衬衫、戴着眼镜的男人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。